hey guys welcome back to the Evan n
Kalin podcast the only podcast that can
grant you the legal right to have a
potato weaken is legalese a boom you're
a potato and you're legally of theta bad
mobile ads there's these mobile ads out
there that say like if you get to level
two you are legally a pumpkin it's like
this is so random if that mobile game
can grant legally grant you the status
as a pumpkin why can't I legally grant
someone who sat us as a potato yeah I
mean we were just driving I think
yesterday and we saw this billboard that
was for a lawyer and it was like
Houston's own lawyer and we're like
that's such a nonsense statement but
then it made us think of that you're
legally a pumpkin like what if whatever
for billboards and traditional media
started doing that like technically like
did what I say is what I said false can
I kindly gali W a potato hoe because
what is legally a potato like a potato
license I don't know you could think of
like why does what is by definition a
potato but like legally my husband has
made you potatoes yeah congrats you are
all potatoes on this glorious day well
welcome back to another Evan Kim podcast
um things things have been really nice
over here we have some exciting news
oh yeah we are legally partners actually
a contract and what does that mean for
people who don't really follow along
with twitch that basically means that
you know okay so you guys probably know
us from YouTube that's where we're
biggest but we also have been playing
games on twitch twitch is a streaming
platform where most people play games
although there are people doing art and
other things now and when you first
start you're just you just our streamer
then you can reach partner status
affiliate affiliate status where you
start making money and as a partner
there's kind of some additional perks
unlocked and and everything like that
basically it's just gonna allow us to
keep on continuing with the gaming stuff
we've been doing and get more legit over
there
we get more emotes moar emotes more
opportunities and more check mark the
dang purple check so excited it
shouldn't matter as much as it does but
it does when YouTube took away
everyone's great check people were upset
so hard for that I was like explaining
it to my mom and I was like it's like
it's like a whole thing I think your mom
had never even seen it didn't even know
that we have mark but then after that so
that's really exciting new news topic
one other thing that we've been up to
recently that's been that's been
successful in the end
guys brainstorming ideas this could be a
whole topic and another we should make
it a whole a whole topic at some point I
feel like we already have done a topic
on how we come up with ideas oh yeah I
think that things have changed as we've
refined how we make videos how we do
with titles and thumbnails and how we
think about the videos that we're doing
because you know when we commit to a
project that's 30 hours each for us
mm-hmm or so that's 60 hours and whether
or not it does okay amazing or poorly
all revolves around the idea like there
are a lot of you guys that would
probably watch almost but most of our
videos unless they were really really
bad in some strange way there's a lot of
people that pick and choose they pick
and choose and also most of our viewers
come from Nam subscribers which is a
cool place to be and that means that we
have a big reach but then you know it's
like the success of our videos relies on
us doing something a little bit strange
a little bit interesting a unique twist
a new
use of a material what have you and
there have been humans on this earth
doing new things for a long time so it's
like you you have to kind of put a
little thought and time into these ideas
if we were just to do another you know
standard table okay why why are we doing
that are we contributing something new
into the world of ideas are we gonna
provide some extra entertaining juicy
content I don't know
so these are the things that run through
our minds a lot and it's also a balance
between are we being too silly or are we
being put to practical with our content
is the mix right well how does it affect
one gradual that's a big part of it
because we have a list of no joke
probably a hundred different ideas that
we've been collecting over the past few
years and a lot of times that's what
we'll pull from but then during these
brainstorming sessions we're at the
point of like actually eating to execute
it you know we'll go through ideas and
were like these ten right here are like
top tier ideas I really want to do them
but none of those we can tackle in the
next week and a half like it's not
possible try not to do too many resumes
yeah I want to become the resin Channel
easily like wrestle yeah yeah exactly
where it's like we did two projects with
resin that means we can't do another
project that has resin or we did two you
know we did a couple like sillier things
that means it needs to be like a more
practical build like there's all these
various things that we try to balance
and basically we went down this
brainstorming path to like 90% on one
idea that took a bunch of planning we
purchased a bunch of items we like
special ordered some stuff and then we
were like wait there's some variables
here that we haven't that like actually
make this not really work and we don't
have time to figure them out yeah as if
we tried it and it didn't week and we
couldn't figure them out there was no
time to switch gears and do another
project so yeah that idea the the
underlying concept was like pretty good
but then when it came to actually
executing it when we started planning
out the details right
wait there's this and then this and then
that you we're gonna be losing one of
the aspects of this that made the
project interesting and that least which
gives Carly and we brainstorm for two
days that's a lot of rain storming but
but I mean at the same time I think it's
worth it because we weren't just
brainstorming one idea we have generated
a whole bunch ideas and a whole bunch of
leads we can start working down those on
the side like while Caitlin is editing
I'll start you know doing the CAD or
sourcing materials and supplies and
figuring out like okay we can either
hand to make this or we can find the
perfect things on the internet to order
that we'll do the same thing but that
will save us 12 hours yeah it was worth
putting a few hours into that I think
one of the biggest things though about
brainstorming that makes it slightly
less frustrating now is before if we
devoted a whole day to brainstorming
like even if we came out at the end with
an idea it still felt like so much
quote-unquote wasted time and that was
really hard especially when our schedule
was a lot tighter and there's less
wiggle room but I feel like now that
we've had several of these extra hung
brainstorming sessions and we've since
used ideas that at the time that they
were brainstormed you know we just like
jotted them down but we're like no it's
not the right one for right now but then
we've gone back and used them and then I
think that makes me now be more able to
see the brainstorming days is like I
mean it's still kind of frustrating when
it takes so long but it I see it more as
an investment it's another big change
that's undergone the brainstorming
process for us is when we were so rushed
the amount of stress that we went
through when we didn't have an idea and
we had to scramble and then we had to
order supplies and then they took two
days to come in and we didn't have the
things that we needed and we knew that
we were just gonna pay horribly for that
time later on we just weren't able to
enjoy brainstorming weren't we weren't
able to enjoy those days that we were
brainstorming and where we were waiting
and I think the biggest change is now
that we have a less aggressive schedule
that has a little bit of wiggle room
built in we haven't been able to get
ahead we haven't been able to like build
up a lead but we have been able to live
a life that we can enjoy a lot more of
our days yeah it's not a stressful cuz
like we we have a good life and
everything but when we had so little
time in our schedule a day could be just
ruined if anything went wrong
yeah because we just didn't have that
day to spare yeah so I think that when
we build in build a reasonable schedule
into our life we've benefited so much
from it oh my gosh in like four weeks I
was just about okay sorry speaking of
things that take up all your time today
we're gonna take it talk about tick tock
which has been like Caitlyn's new time
sock you know that like thing that you
do like for a lot of people it's tick
tock our friend we're a lot of
eulogistic talk but like before for me
it was reddit I'd like it pulled into
reddit every now and then or for some
people they just keep on browsing or
whatever whatever that thing is that
like you pull up in your idle moments
that think that you're some
automatically goes to even when it's not
the app you meant to pull up and then
all of a sudden you're like I was gonna
check my calendar but now I'm on so
Kailyn how did your tik-tok obsession
start it's because you were being
responsible and you wanted to research
right I wanted to research well cuz I
mean so many people were talking about
it and like from a business perspective
social media perspective I was very
interested and because the best time to
get in on a platform is early yeah yeah
yeah like the best time is right when
it's starting up the second best time is
immediately yeah and like when you're
listening
you know when you when you hear about it
from like your younger cousins you're
like okay you know but then when you
hear about it from people that you don't
expect to be on it and they're even on
it too and then you're like dang it
should I be on it so I remember
listening to like the made for profit
podcast which is like a maker business
podcast and they were talking about it
and it was like okay maybe we should
look into it
well and let's give a little background
tik-tok is an app for your phone where
you watch videos you you you can't
really use it on any other device it's
not made for desktop viewing or anything
like that you can view the videos there
but that's not at all what it's meant
and it's 15 to 60 second videos and I
think like the misconception which is
the misconception I had but I think a
lot of people have is that it's mostly
like lip syncing and dancing well that's
where it got its start the app started
as musically and basically all it was is
people dancing and lip-syncing that was
pretty much it but now it's just become
like a video platform your format video
platform but like on top of that I think
the distinctive feature is it's just
like made for memes it's not it's a meme
isn't really the right word but like
everything is to a trend the trends in
the same way that memes trend where like
one person will do a meme and it'll get
big and then like there's all these
subtle variations and it grows and
changes and grows and changes and then
like it it's like a big inside joke if
you are familiar with the meme and other
people don't get it
and the trends will ask from a day or
two to like months and the reason that
it it like is so conducive to this is
because the way it works is audio from
any single tick-tock you can say use
this audio and then record your own
tick-tock
to that audio and it's like it
encourages it so you know one person
will upload a song or select a song or
it might just be like their own audio
like they might Judy talking to the
camera whatever it is it'll get popular
and that other people will just use that
audio use that audio
audio and so it's or we mix it or tweak
it to come up with their own version and
I'll spread and again or what happened
but it's like built for that so it's
really interesting being on there and
starting to like see the trends and you
know decide which ones you like decide
which ones you don't like and I don't
know it's a lot it's interesting also
because when I first opened it up I
didn't really know where to go so like I
was just on the quote-unquote for you
page which is like the home page and
that's there like super algorithm heavy
page and at first I didn't want to hurt
anything because I didn't know like well
people see what videos I've hearted you
know and so I would just watch and it
wasn't you know it was like okay but it
wasn't great once I start Harding stuff
it like knew me immediately because you
hearted caps and you got more caps you
have it I heard it like funny things
yeah um and it's it's interesting well
cuz I'm also like I'm guessing that if
you go on to this a bike tik-tok and you
heart all the sing-along ones all and
then you'll just get more sin along
lines or heart the dancing ones you'll
get more dancing ones you'll write like
comedy skits you'll get a comedy yeah so
it's very interesting yeah Caitlyn
protects me from the worst of like going
through the garbage tik-tok because we
share an account because we have so many
counts already so when I got on tik-tok
Kalin had been using tick tock for yeah
oh I remember the weeks at first I was
like do I should I like follow a hashtag
or something or go to like a category so
I went to like the DIY and crafting
category and I just like clicked on a
few of the thumbnails then one was this
like girl dancing and I was like this
isn't crafting and I got upset both
advertising false advertising false
tagging so it was very upset and then I
was like I'm not going to that to the
like categories pages anymore they're
all false oh um oh yeah but then
eventually it started like learning me
learning me yeah I guess learning me I
guess everything words right words are
hard anyways um and I remember like
around Christmas is when I really
getting sucked into it and I kept like I
would show you one every now and then
but the main thing is I kept getting the
songs in my head a lot and then it's not
you come in my head it's not just songs
it's also like statements to that you
can say in response to many situations
and then their sake he's dead there's
like so you don't like they only make
sense if you've watched enough tick
tocks and know how to use like what goes
along with that like sound at first I
was just quoting them like myself to you
and I'd have to explain it every time
but then finally finally I got addicted
to gather other buckle crazy I'm not
fully addicted like Caitlyn is I know I
don't you you're probably like five
times more addicted in terms of watch
time maybe more research very important
research research well let's let's move
on to some of our first impressions like
one thing that was very interesting to
me because I was looking at this like a
business I was looking at this like as a
content creator and as I like this
platform to see what what its strategy
was and one thing that's very
interesting is I noticed that there are
a lot of just people just normal people
not full-time content creators not
whatever like you know how Instagram has
a lot of users on it but the only people
you follow are your family your friends
that's all you've seen your feed
unless you hear about someone somewhere
else or you want to follow some famous
person or whatever then you follow their
feed and then Instagram will show it to
you more or less depending on how much
you engage with that person with tik-tok
it's just everyone is making content and
if the algorithm deems that this normal
person's tik-tok that they recorded on a
random Saturday of them making a funny
voice in front of their mirror is worth
showing to millions of people so be it
this this just
dude or lady whatever the dinner like
random funny thing they didn't even
think about it that is did it and now it
has like 12 million views no if the
amount of exposure it it can thrust
people into unexpectedly dislike you
know so you might get on tick-tock just
like make tic TOCs with your friends or
like you know like people might use it
like Instagram except the algorithm
might like pluck that thing and blow it
up an insane amount because some people
are trying for that yeah I think a lot
of people are trying but some people
might not be yeah interestingly in the
feed like in the for you feed I can be
scrolling and see like video with two
million views and monovalent video with
literally zero views and I'm not calling
the first view yeah you know and or not
views hearts but because I don't think
it shows you views unless you tap on it
anyways
it's very interesting because it seems
much more democratic in like okay it's
not based on previous clout yeah you
know now that does help that does seem
to help like the more followers you have
the higher a chance you have of getting
that like boom for you but it seems like
it's less biased than Instagram or
YouTube yeah so let's talk about our
journey on tick-tock by the way we have
a tick-tock I think we might have
mentioned it the podcast is probably the
very first place we mentioned it we
mentioned it I think once on the podcast
and then once honest or twice on a
stream once or twice on a stream and
when we started when we uploaded our
very first video how many followers did
we have 77 do we had 70 followers which
is it's a number it is something it's
more than zero so we had 70 followers
and we launched our first video yeah
there our first two videos are just me
messing around trying to learn how to
edit on tick-tock and then the third
video put a lot of effort into yeah I
mean I do
effort and it's not really tick-tock II
like half of our two thirds of our stuff
on there isn't really tick-tock II cuz
it's just me taking footage from our
videos and like trying to make it work
in a tick-tock format but I did like a
you know 60-second version of our cactus
video so is our third video and then
from that one video from the first two
videos I'm not sure if we got like any
growth at all we got like a few hundred
few hundred views and then after that
one video that Kalyn put like that extra
love into we got over 15,000 followers
and half a million views which in 24
hours and 24 hours we've never done that
on YouTube yes to put that in
perspective in terms of watch time it's
a lot less it was 60 seconds of content
but for half million people to see that
that type of insane growth and views and
potential that that kind of definitely
caught my attention a lot more than I
had previously given Tech Talk I was
like wow and you know in terms of
monetization it's not there you can't
unless you're doing like a sponsor deal
with a company but that's also hard do
on tik-tok because if it's not getting
engagement it's not gonna be shown to
anyone
tik-tok is even more algorithm heavy
than any other I think once you're
bigger you can probably guess the
minimum amount of yeah maybe because
like when I click on people's profiles
you can kind of see trends if you've
been doing it long enough I think you
could guess like a minimum amount of use
but I mean on YouTube we're making
twenty five minutes of content and we
embed a sixty second advertisement
within that twenty five minutes and that
balance is is pretty good I think in
terms of general cost better than TV
better than TV you know but for if you
only have 60 seconds or less if you're
gonna do an advertisement or an
integration it being good it has to be
the whole thing and the integration has
to be highly entertaining of and
shareable and common to both otherwise
it's going to tank and be bad yeah
and I don't know do you sponsor stuff on
I don't know either seems so far away
right now we're just trying to like
learn it right now it's like you know
we're investing time into it because
Kaitlyn and Joey's tik-tok but also
because we see some growth advertising
like awareness spreading because on the
internet as people who make content for
the Internet
the more people have seen you and or
and/or are aware of you the better it is
just in general for whatever future
thing we do so spreading brand awareness
which is strange thing to say it's just
our faces it's just us our names that is
beneficial to us as a company yeah it is
it is interesting oh yeah in the video
that cactus video so it's been like a
week and a half now and now it's at 1.2
million views and we're at 37 K
followers and since then we've done like
five or so other videos none of them
have done as good I think merely ones
over a hundred thousand we have a couple
in the twenty is we have a couple like
under ten so clearly it's like we got
lucky it's soon going to be our biggest
social media account which is I mean you
know besides YouTube YouTube is our
number one largest like we've been
building our Instagram for over three
years now and we just passed fifty
thousand tic TOCs gonna pass that yeah
I'm like a couple weekly and we still we
haven't even like announced it on our
yeah we had all once shared that we have
a Tech Talk on YouTube or any videos or
or Twitter past and live streams yeah
and and that start that started off with
a uh that helped us gain seventy people
yeah which is like okay that's not
nothing not nothing but it's not the
highest compression side nothing it I
know that people who are watching the
podcast may not care about tick tock you
know like that that's why we're putting
our our content on a whole bunch of
platforms because everyone has a
favorite way to engage with the Internet
some people don't like other like some
people don't like Twitter they don't
have twitter for first whatever reason
or
everything yeah except for snapchat
Nevers that's redundant having a
snapchat doesn't add anything that I can
see
well because Instagram does stories this
is one of the biggest thing is about
Tech Talk though discovery
discoverability is the at the heart of
tic-tock tic-tock is always shoving new
things in your face and seeing if they
stick right what about this what about
this what about this what about this on
Instagram they only show you what you
want yeah besides ads what you want
Plus ads but there's no discoverability
built-in I mean there's the homepage
I've never gone to the explore page and
followed someone because of that every
once in a while I'll go there just to be
like what what Instagram showing I think
most growth for us at least because
we're that type of channel I mean like
maybe you you you 100 of people do this
but like what if you wanted to add memes
to your page yeah I guess you could like
browse memes or browse just random dogs
and cats that are cute and just follow
some of that on Instagram but for us no
one's really just gonna be browsing
Instagram and see us and say oh yeah I
want to follow along with them and I
care about them and their story and
their journey but for tik-tok I think
there is a high possibility for organic
growth on that platform because of the
discoverability and I think that's one
of the weight reasons it stands out a
lot amongst all the other platforms for
us so I think also um I at first didn't
really know how to view it because for
platforms there's social media platforms
and then there are content platforms
tik-tok is a little bit of both but it's
more on I think it's 100% content I
think of social media as like like what
depends on how you use it some people
use it kind of like to do behind the
scenes like social media type things I
mean social
I don't know social media I think is
mostly about interaction yeah and I
think content sites are mostly about
entertainment now it really depends I
mean within tick tock kind of like
within YouTube within YouTube there's
all sorts of videos all sorts of vibes
all sorts of different intents and
everything like that and when tick tock
was musically there's only one thing
people dancing people up sinking but as
tick tock has gotten bigger is mainly
this a place to distribute short content
short form content and it can be
whatever if you're big enough because
there's a whole bunch of celebrities and
people coming on this platform and if
you're big enough you can use it however
the heck you want and you're still gonna
get enough views and engagement so
there's some like TV show personalities
or movie personalities just like hey I'm
behind the scenes and I'm here doing
whatever yeah and like that kind of goes
against what tick tock was was grown as
and what most people use it as but
they're still finding some certain
amount of success just by doing that so
it is just like content delivery yeah
self more to content the content
platform than being a social media
platform I think that's what it's best
used for yeah it's also interesting
because like if you think about other
apps like Instagram or Twitter or reddit
um you consume it in a more like
multitasking kind of way like most
people don't sit aside time to like well
here's my Instagram 20 minutes and I'm
just gonna do this most people pull it
up if they're like oh I'm waiting on
like the oven to heat up or I'm like
standing lay at the grocery store or
like I have a show on but it's not that
great I'm gonna browse you know but
because
tick tock relies on you actively
listening and watching it's kind of just
like short YouTube you know where you
have to rapid-fire you to rapid-fire
YouTube YouTube roulette so it's so
YouTube roulette
like tiny YouTube relax tiny YouTube
roulette and so it's interesting because
you can't just do it passively or while
you're doing something
as easily because one I mean I guess
like if you had your headphones on you
could do it out in public but like it
just requires more attention you know
let's get into the positives and
negatives of Tech Talk in our short and
a short few months stay oh yeah you've
been on it for months
yeah I started like before December Wow
okay so months February okay so my one
month of experience with it because
there's been a lot less for me the
positives that I see kind of relate to
it more from like a like logic and
business point of view in a way I I just
think it's really interesting because
when when YouTube was first starting out
from the stories I've heard not that I
was you know we were there in early
YouTube but it was like very much all
about you it was just about like
individual creators and giving them a
platform and this very Wild West but
organic type of growth and there were
some people kind of abusing the system
but it was very much like you the you
part of YouTube was strong and as
YouTube has grown as a platform and
gotten bigger and and companies
recognized the potential for for
monetization and marketing and all of
the different things that YouTube can be
made used for like a lot of the biggest
viewer like viewership channels on
YouTube are like a ton of music videos a
ton of like like bigger companies and
stuff and and as like the the reach and
power of YouTube has expanded YouTube
has had to just because of how powerful
it is they've had to regulate it more
they've had to control it more and I
feel like in a way it like you know
they're they're having some like people
complaining that YouTube isn't as much
about you anymore it's about bigger
things but that's no problem that's
not--that's through no fault of YouTube
that's just because YouTube has gotten
so much
publicity power and attention that that
has had to like put those measures in
place to protect kids to protect
politics to protect all of these things
I mean they're they're under a lot of
pressure like YouTube is is got too
powerful it has became too powerful when
YouTube was tiny and flying under the
radar yeah it could be about like this
people and people doing whatever and
everything but like YouTube is now the
second biggest search engine in the
world Google which also shows YouTube
videos if you like like the number one
and number two portals that people use
the internet with basically tie into
YouTube and YouTube is that just puts
YouTube in such a powerful place that
they've had to put rules and
restrictions in place which so you like
the Wild West ness of tick-tock I kind
of like the Wild West mists of tick-tock
it's kind of like it kind of reminds me
of this video that we watched about vine
who drew gooden drew gooden did a very
interesting video on Viners where are
they now and you kind of reflected back
on vine and the the history of it and
everything like that and and one thing
that was very interesting to him is or
an interesting aspect of volume to him
was it was the first rung in the ladder
of climbing multimedia you know it
allowed people to go from zero to that
first rung where they gathered an
audience and I think that that might be
an interesting parallel between YouTube
and tick-tock where you can get huge
exposure if you like come up the right
clever thing or get out of the right
hashtag you can even blow up an
interesting ways on tick-tock and then
you can maybe ride that to something
more to something different
to some platform where you can monetize
a little bit more which i think is
interesting but I think that another
aspect of things is if you aren't
utilizing this other platforms then
like what's the point of tech talk as a
business I'm not sure popular and don't
care about that they're like young yeah
it making money isn't the priority right
now and that doesn't mean to say that
this is all about
wow it's all about like yeah that's not
to say that they're not business minded
yeah you know they may know that like
building an audience can be valuable for
them but whether or not you're not
paying bills yeah so like the money
doesn't really matter
yeah but also I wonder like if you are
16 and you have 5 million followers on
tik-tok and and you have this social
clout but you haven't yet figured out
how to monetize that you don't know
about the ins and outs of merch and tax
and sales tax
oh well like you you haven't encountered
those logistics I wonder if people are
getting like fall census of their
monetizable miss you know like is that
is that something that's gonna be
happening people like who are famous on
tik-tok and they're 17 they graduate
high school
and then they say I don't need college I
have five million Tik Tok followers and
then they try to do it like a merge
launch and then they get fined by the
state of California for like like
selling within their state without
proper licensing like is that is that
going to be the story that we're reading
about in one or two years I don't know
it's gonna be sad that'd be sad don't do
that if any famous tick stalkers are
listening to this podcast to all all of
them makes it sound so old you know for
dick dot we are probably above the
average age although one thing that
surprised me was there's a lot of people
like in their late 20s early 30s oh
there's so many old people it's
hilarious oh yeah these old people do
all my grandma's grandpa's that one old
couple
she's hilarious they put out a lot of
content how they do if I was if I was
like retired
I'm buddy megyn tik toks - what do you
fellas like it's just fun you know I
think like interestingly so like I like
it a lot as a consumer of it hmm when we
first when I first did my first couple
like super janky edited videos that I
edited in the tic-tock app I liked it as
a user of it once I figured out how to
edit I was like oh it's kind of fun I
just like take one of the trending
audios and I like do my own thing to it
this is fun and then when I edited the
cat kiss one editing it I was like man
this feels like like work kind of and
then I think once you're done with it
you're like if this doesn't do well I'm
never doing this again yeah and then it
did well and then I did yeah and then
and then there's like what do you do do
you chase that like million and million
views and all of those followers like or
do you just have fun doing silly videos
it's like what I want to do is just do
silly stuff but if I'm thinking about it
from a business perspective we should do
things that at least relate cuz I don't
I don't see us monetizing on tik-tok
anytime soon or like doing spa yeah we
don't even like do that on like it's a
super rare that we even do a sponsored
like Instagram or Twitter post it's just
so annoying like we only do it if brands
really really worry we also don't want
to bother you guys it's not like like
compared to what our our income earning
potential on YouTube that's worth extra
effort and that's worth like you know
trying to make the best it can be for
you guys entertaining but also like
that's how our business runs you know we
what we run off of sponsors it's still
60% or more of our income comes from
sponsors but like compared to the amount
we can earn on YouTube the amount we can
earn on Instagram or Twitter isn't like
really worth it
yeah worth the bother so I don't see s
like monetizing on tik-tok pretty soon
so for me if I'm doing
from like okay business perspective yeah
the main reason is like to introduce
other people to us who might get curious
and look us up on other platforms yeah
so if I'm thinking of it from that
perspective then like our videos should
be like project slash making related
they should have us and yeah you know
and we've and our personality all you're
doing there's dancing and you do a
really good dance are people gonna
follow you follow you well yeah that's
like a huge percentage of tick stalkers
yeah it's just foreign to me I know but
that's not what I'm saying
yeah what I'm saying is if our goal is
to have people fine oh you tube oh
you're like we need to hook them with
something that is indicative of what's
on our YouTube you know what I mean it
is so funny if like we just like went
all in with the dancing trend and we
practice all the dance
I thought that they were gonna be
dancing here fashion tips
why are they dancing why what's up of
those resin oh like I don't wanna like
bait and switch but I also just want to
like do dumb stuff that follows the
trends that I think is funny I think one
of the downsides of tik-tok though
because everything is so reliant on the
algorithm and everything like you know
people don't go - people don't get
alerts for when you upload a tic toc
people don't you might be able to sign
up for that we don't follow anyone might
be different if we actually followed
people I think they'll just show up in
here for you more frequently no I get
notifications you can notification yeah
I turned them off but it was just like
things that the algorithm like Wow based
on our experience so far of one month
and and three three months on kaitlin's
part the well I guess it's like the few
weeks where we've been posting videos
the views are all over the place and
look from looking at other people's
profiles that's a very common theme and
on YouTube with with the content we've
crafted our business around
have been able to get fairly reliable
views and I feel like that's a really
good sign of success in a way on
tick-tock we just don't even know what
success looks like don't even know to do
on there and I was like oh I haven't
found anyone who this constantly kills
it I well I found one I think it's gonna
it's gonna be my pick my thing of the
week okay
well I'll get there later neat well I
think that um is that is that a good
place to wrap up I'm tick it's time for
our thing of the week well here we have
one one last note what do we think the
future of tick tock hold oh yeah okay so
tick tock has to make money they're a
company and they saw what happened to
vine yeah so now when you open up tick
tock now I've noticed an ad get an ad my
gosh was like the easiest way to
monetize more as you swipe there are
official sponsored advertisements oh so
that could be all they need I mean I
think that's probably turned the valve
on that up and down as you need more or
less money that's probably all they need
themselves oh yeah the other part of it
if you're not one of me this was one of
the like faults of vine is a bunch of
the like top Viners got together and
demanded to be paid and vine was like
we're not making money we can't we can't
pay you so like if that repeats itself
on tick tock and a bunch of creators
threatened to leave if they don't get
paid they're gonna have to find some way
to like do built-in monetization now
that may not be an issue because you
know on vine in six seconds is probably
a lot harder to do a sponsored post
whereas on tick-tock people are already
working with brands independently the
same way they do on Instagram you know
Instagram doesn't have built-in
monetization yeah and there's plenty of
people that are full-time instagramers
so it could just stay as is [ __ ] it's
you know built-in ads but no creator
monetization yeah
but I do feel like they might lose some
people to YouTube because if you already
have yeah well I don't know if they've
lost people but we've
some tick talkers on YouTube yeah that
are like trying to start their YouTube
channels based off their tick-tock
success yeah that's very interesting
well we'll just have to see how things
go I mean your tick-tock has been around
in some form as musically for like what
three years yeah I don't know they've
survived for a while yeah now and and
it's just gonna be interesting to see
what happens for us and for the platform
as a whole well let you know probably in
like six months to a year how things
have gone but but you know we're
starting and it's very interesting yeah
it's like a fun game to play yeah all
right guys it's time for thing of the
week
alright so my thing of the week is
paradise tropical tea YUM it's it's a it
comes in a 50 pack that's the only way
we've been able to find and that'll last
you for a long time
but if you're making iced tea at home
and you want it to taste like that
delicious fancy tea that you get at
restaurants this is how to do it is by
your own fantasy delicious tea and you
have in your refrigerator and it comes
in like a like the tea bag it's pretty
big so it's enough for like one of those
like Tomorrowland rug yeah things yeah
like two gallon tea canister type of
things so it's not like you have to do
you know 10 individual little tea bags
it's like mint for making large amounts
of iced tea it's so good it's so good
and it's so intense I actually like we
brew it full strength and then I
actually add a little bit of water and
lemonade on top and it's amazing yeah do
you want to say why that's your pick do
you remember uh we were in a livestream
and Chad asked us what our favorite tea
was yeah we said I think of the week so
that we could and we wrote down and we
remembered yes okay so my thing of the
week in in theme with this episode in
case you're like I'm gonna check out tic
toc but I don't know where to start
I'm gonna recommend a tick-tock er who I
like um her handle is oddity drawers and
it's a UD ity drawers and she's an art
account is she the one that did the yeah
I spent often there well that's cute I
like yeah so she's she's an artist she
was like a really cute kind of cartoony
style and she has like various series
that she does the one that got me was
where she hurt me link to that once in
particular sure her husband made this
like drawing prompter generator so you
would like click it and it would scroll
through a bunch of people slash
characters and it would give you like a
person or character and then it would
give you them
give you a like situation to draw them
in so like the first video over as I saw
it was Gordon Ramsay as a magic princess
girl and it's like the best thing but
it's really fast because she's she's
doing kind of like funny commentary as
she draws it and then often like there's
a lot of personality often her husband
is next to her or in the other room or
like comes by and it's like what are you
doing she's like don't judge me you know
but it's really funny like them
interacting and it's very wholesome so
she has like the random generator series
she has one where it's like drawing
States as people I keep waiting room
taxes she hasn't done in Texas yet but
she's done a bunch of them she does
various things but that's great that's a
great series because you want to see
your state I know yeah but yeah so
oddity draws will link bullying to the
Gordon Ramsay because it's so good yeah
alright guys well that's that that's a
wrap on today's podcast Asian with us as
we space ease out a little bit more it
really has been so good I think I've
said that in like the last three of
these podcasts so feeling it still
feeling it yeah alright guys well if you
felt this podcast I would really
appreciate it if you gave us a five star
review if you share it with a friend a
family member or if you do other things
that support it it's like we're on so
many platforms I'm like what do people
do for podcast again what's the thing
that I asked them to do I mean you could
also just say the same thing that we do
on YouTube videos which is like
subscribe to the podcast channel or
leave a comment oh yeah yeah do those
things alright guys see you next time
bye
[Music]